Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a Polish cult
comedy science fiction film called “Seksmisja.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
In 1991, two common men named Max Paradys
and Albert Starski volunteer for the first
human hibernation experiment.
Max is looking for adventure in his life and
a time away from his wife and daughter while
Albert is a biologist who wants to be known
for something great.
Hence, they are ready to go into hibernation
pods created by professor Wiktor Kuppelweiser.
The professor is a Nobel Prize laureate, who
has successfully hibernated a chimpanzee for
half a year, so the men believe they will
be safe.
The experiment is considered a revolutionary
event that is about to change the course of
human history.
In the official announcement of the initiation
of the experiment, it is said that the hibernation
is scheduled to last for 3 years.
Max and Albert are finally put into the pods
as the world watches in anticipation.
However, Instead of being awakened 3 years
later in 1994 as planned, they wake up in
the year 2044.
They have been in the pod for fifty-three
years but haven't aged a day.
Unknown to this, When the two wake up, they
believe that they are in a facility following
their post-hibernation checkup.
They are joyful as they anticipate fame and
money for their bravery.
The facility keeps them in confinement for
some days as they are taken care of by women.
As time goes by, the two start suspecting
why they haven’t seen a single man since
they woke up.
One of their caretakers is named Lamia Reno.
She keeps an eye on the two through cameras
and observes them all day.
On the third day, they explicitly ask to meet
professor Kuppelweiser.
But are informed by Lamia and doctor Berna
that Kuppelweiser doesn't exist.
They explain to the guys that a nuclear war
broke out several years ago which caused all
males of the world to go extinct.
The date currently is the 8th of March 2044,
meaning that the guys are eighty-six years
old.
Max and Albert refuse to believe this and
assume that they are being tested upon.
They also realize that the room they are staying
in has no windows and try to leave through
the door, only to receive an electric shock.
At night, the men are distressed and still
confused.
Lamia senses their confusion and talks to
them through a microphone fitted in their
room.
She reveals that their society reproduces
without males through a process called parthenogenesis.
The women suppress their sexual urges by taking
a mandatory drug, so there is no need for
men altogether.
While watching the television, Max sees that
women frequently walk around naked because
of the absence of men.
He gets an idea to take advantage of their
situation and get with as many women as possible
because there are no male competitors.
So, during a briefing, Max kisses Lamia to
test the waters.
She furiously accuses him of sexual assault
and knocks him down easily.
A few days later, Max and Albert are summoned
by the supreme leader of the women, Her Excellency.
They are taken to a bio sanctuary where post-war
animals and trees are preserved.
In the meeting, they ask what exactly happened
to mankind and how did men extinct.
The women explain that the extinction was
men’s own fault.
In the war, doctor Kuppelweiser invented an
agent called the M bomb.
The bomb was supposed to temporarily paralyze
male genes that he planned to use as a bioweapon.
But due to an oversight, it destroyed male
genes permanently, causing the extinction
of male species.
Max offers to serve as reproducers to restore
the male population, and change the society
to how it was.
However, the women do not wish the old order
to return because they have been taught that
men terrorized and enslaved them back in the
day.
After the meeting, the guys are taken back
to confinement but Lamia cannot get the thought
of Max out of her head.
The kiss has caused her drug-inhibited passions
to resurface.
Due to her internal feelings, she goes on
a search for the oldest living woman to find
out anything she can about the men before
the war.
She finds 74-year old Julia and shows her
a video of Max and Albert showering.
Seeing the guys naked reminds Julia of her
fiancé.
According to her, the world with both sexes
should be restored.
Lamia leaves with a new way to look at life
after the meeting.
Meanwhile, as Max and Albert stay in confinement
they grow distressed.
Albert sees wires on their room’s floor
and devises a plan to escape by damaging the
electric power grid.
They put their plan into action the next day
and easily succeed.
While running around, they end up in a room
where little girls are being taught how to
interact with men if they were ever to come
in contact with them.
Soon, the guys are caught and are locked up
again.
After the commotion, the women are furious,
but they still provide Max and Albert a chance
to redeem themselves.
They want the guys to undergo sex reassignment
surgery and turn into women to be accepted
in society.
When they refuse, the ceiling above the room
opens, showing a huge assembly of women, who
are to determine their fate.
The hearing starts and goes on for a long
time as the assembly blames men for oppression,
virtually all evil and vices, and praises
their new society.
They even claim that the greatest scientists
- such as Copernicus, Einstein, and Pincus
were, in fact, women.
When Max and Albert are taken away, the assembly
votes on whether the men should undergo forced
'naturalization' or be 'liquidated'.
Lamia thinks she should have a say in the
matter because she is the one who dug the
hibernation pod and found them.
However, voting takes place and Naturalization
is passed by a margin of only one vote.
As the discussion is taking place, the men
escape again, wandering through the facility
and getting lost every few minutes.
All the women they encounter have never seen
a man before so they mistake the two for fellow
“sisters”.
Max is distracted on the way by naked girls
swimming in an aquarium.
After that, the men escape down a waste chute
where they discover a group of women singing,
dancing, and having fun.
Some of them are also engaging in lesbian
relations which fascinates Max.
It turns out that the group consists of rebellious
hippies who do not want to follow Her Excellency’s
order.
They mistake Max and Albert for government
spies.
Soon, the police force comes looking for them
and they manage to escape only to be caught
by Lamia again.
She tells them that the facility they are
living in is underground and takes them to
the entrance.
Then, using a periscope they watch the current
condition of the surface of the earth.
It is a dark, rocky landscape above ground
that has high levels of "Kuppelweiser radiation",
a side effect of the M bomb.
She shows them the reality so they would quit
trying to escape.
The officials praise her for her intelligence
but do not provide her full authority over
the men which devastates Lamia.
Instead, Max and Albert are handed to an old
doctor named Yanda.
She decides that the men’s organs will be
extracted for transplantation, and their remains
will be tested for possible use as a food
source, due to a growing protein shortage.
When Max is on the hospital bed, it is revealed
that Yanda is actually his daughter, who now
hates him because he abandoned her mother
when she was little.
Both men are strapped to the hospital bed
being prepared for the surgery when Lamia
comes to their aid.
She helps them escape as revenge for the officials
taking the men.
Shortly after escaping, Albert passes out
in the elevator from the anesthetic given
to him.
As Lamia tries to revive him, he dreams that
he's in 1994, and the process of hibernation
has successfully finished.
After he comes back to his senses, they rush
to the periscope room, planning to escape
to the surface, despite the radiation.
Lamia threatens the guards to give her the
code to activate a capsule that will take
them to the surface, but the guards claim
they do not know it.
In the meantime, Max and Albert quickly change
into protective suits.
The guards claim that only Her Excellency
knows the password which makes the three believe
they are about to be caught.
Enraged, Max curses, saying “your mother's
a whore”, and to the surprise of all present,
the capsule is activated.
Lamia also changes into another protective
suit and the three finally make it to the
surface.
While exploring it, Max walks a few steps
and suddenly bumps against something that
seems to be an invisible barrier.
He takes a knife and cuts the fabric of the
barrier, revealing daylight on the other side.
They all go through the hole and to their
utmost surprise, find themselves on a beach.
The area that was visible with the periscope
was surrounded by a small, circular tent-like
structure with the barren landscape panorama
painted on the inside of the canvas.
The three explore their surroundings and eventually
reach a forest.
The guys are joyful to finally see a sight
of their old lives.
However, the suits start running out of oxygen.
Suddenly Max shouts with joy and throws away
his suit, pointing upwards to a flying stork.
According to him, if the bird can breathe,
it means they can too.
They take their suits off and are wooshed
with fresh oxygen.
A while later, they come across a fully furnished
cozy villa full of fresh food and modern technology.
They are confused about who it belongs to
but do not question the matter further.
Instead, the three enjoy a delicious meal
in the garden.
Meanwhile, back in the facility, Lamia’s
coworker named Emma gets in a suit and comes
out looking for the three.
Since there is only one suit left, the others
wish her luck and stay back.
She also finds out that the world outside
is completely different than what they had
thought.
Eventually, she finds Lamia, Max, and Albert
eating in the garden and points her weapon
at them.
But she faints due to the lack of oxygen.
Albert removes her helmet and performs CPR
on her.
He carries her inside the villa and starts
to remove her suit.
She quickly regains consciousness and feels
attracted towards Albert.
Max, on the other hand, goes with Lamia to
a bedroom and explains to her what mating
is.
At last, both couples have intercourse.
Later, the girls are in the bath while the
men are resting in the living room.
Max and Albert hear a noise and hide, assuming
it is the owner of the house.
A few seconds later, Her Excellency emerges
from an elevator hidden within a closet.
Max attacks her, demanding answers.
During the ensuing fight, Her Excellency's
breasts and hair are stripped, revealing that
he is actually a male in disguise.
'Her' Excellency finally tells the men his
life story - just after the war, when the
League of Women took power, he was 4 years
old; the few boys remaining were naturalized
into girls, but he was hidden by his mother.
He joined the League to seem more feminine
and eventually was elected 'Her Excellency'.
He wanted to keep the women confined inside
the facility and rule over them, so he exaggerated
the radiation level in order to keep them
under control.
Max and Albert make a deal with 'Her' Excellency's,
claiming that they will not reveal his true
identity if they are allowed to stay in the
home with Lamia and Emma.
“Her” Excellency accepts the offer.
In the following scene, Max and Albert are
in the facility’s incubation chamber disguised
as laboratory workers.
They add male gametes to incubation flasks,
in order to restore the male sex.
Several months later when the babies are finally
developed.
A nurse is horrified to see a male infant.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.